this is upper albert road in central
hong kong
stand here at just the right time each
month and you'd witness a strange sight
a car delivering 433 000 hong kong
dollars or 55 000 u.s in cash to a
nearby home
inside the house you'd find what could
only be the sure sign of a criminal
stacks and stacks of cash about 670 000
us dollars accumulating each year
no bank no matter how big or small local
or international is brave enough to do
business with this highly suspicious
character
this place is known as government house
and this person is none other than the
chief executive of the hong kong special
administrative region
to be clear this is the highest
authority in the territory its local
equivalent to president or prime
minister
and yet she's completely unable to open
a bank account in her own territory even
by her own banks
because no company whether american
european or chinese will touch her money
carrie lam receives her salary
hand-delivered in cash
with no credit card to make purchases
she has no way of paying for netflix or
doing some online shopping
financially she's been exiled to the
1800s and all while living in one of the
world's best places to shop
the reason for all this is simple
a person in a country 8 000 miles away
signed a piece of paper
the president of the united states and
the hong kong autonomy act
such is the unparalleled power of the
american government and prominence of
the u.s dollar
as long as the world continues
transacting in its currency the world
will have no choice but to play by its
rules
although it will surely never happen the
u.s treasury could in theory make the
state-run bank of china close the
chinese bank account of general
secretary xi jinping
but this exorbitant privilege wielded by
the u.s need not last forever if the
collective world chose the renbin b
instead china would have this power and
a growing number of experts are
concerned exactly that may happen
likely within the next six months to a
year china will become the first major
country to launch a digital currency the
progress of which is years at least
ahead of the us
could this be the beginning of the end
for the us dollar and with it its
ability to financially exile anyone it
wishes
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
get both for just 15 bucks a year and
watch the extended version of this video
over on nebula
the us dollar has seen its fair share of
rivals most recently the euro but even
at its most tenuous moments has still
had plenty of room to fall
today in 2021 it comprises about 60 of
global currency reserves a figure made
only more impressive when compared to
its closest competitors
the next most popular currency is the
euro at only 20 percent
where is china's renminbi way down here
at about two percent if you can even see
it
that's despite the fact that its economy
makes up about 1 6th of the world's gdp
zoom out however and things get a bit
more complicated
some interpret this graph as proving the
dollar is here to stay it is in fact
more widely held now than 40 years ago
others see a market ripe for disruption
its trend however slow is clearly
downward they would argue and besides
currency reserves are very much winner
take all two percent may not sound like
a lot but actually places the renminbi
in fifth place
thanks to network effects if the world
were to change its mind on the dollar
the shift may happen fast with the new
winner taking a dominant position like
the dollar today
which brings us to the digital yuen
while it's still being tested the exact
details are uncertain but it's expected
to launch as early as next february's
winter olympics
officially called the digital currency
electronic payment system the idea is to
make a one-to-one digital version of
cash with many of the same properties
like cash for example you may not need a
bank account and it will have the same
legal status
you'd be able to deposit money from your
bank or an atm and send money to others
directly likely without a fee
if this sounds revolutionary you've
surely never stepped foot in china
while a few of these features might be
novel in most countries china is light
years ahead when it comes to mobile
payments
paying for everything with your phone is
massively more convenient than cash or
credit card
unfortunately china uses neither
at least 85 percent of chinese adults
with access to the internet use mobile
payments for everything from groceries
and gas to paying parking tickets you
won't go 10 steps without seeing one of
these signs
neither does the digital un solve a
problem of fragmentation
94 percent use wechat or alipay in fact
all it does is introduce one more
standard
now you might assume digital means
cryptocurrency but central bank digital
currencies are not in any way
cryptocurrencies neither are they
blockchains
neither are they decentralized or
permissionless
in other words virtually every
limitation of regular cash applies to
digital cash as well
the digital un is the very antithesis of
cryptocurrency the latter promises a
future free from government intervention
a world where no one can be blocked from
the financial system one that is totally
anonymous
whether you see those things as features
or bugs china's invention is the exact
opposite the central bank controls who
can participate the printing of money
and everything in between
some claim it would allow money to move
faster than bank transfers but most
mobile wallets are already instant
some claim it would allow for new and
interesting monetary policies like
making unused stimulus checks expire
after a crisis is over
but experts have rightly pointed out
that this is already possible
so what exactly is special or unique
about it
there is one party for whom this will
truly be revolutionary
the government
while it can and does already request
data from banks and payment platforms
this information is necessarily delayed
and cash goes undetected when payments
are made directly to and from the
central bank authorities will have a
real-time window into every transaction
in the country
nothing will slide under the radar
including money laundering gambling and
any other form of illegal activity
if and when physical cash disappears
there will be nowhere for corrupt
politicians or tax evaders to hide
finally power will shift from private
companies like ant and tencent over to
the state
companies may design the apps and
interfaces that citizens interact with
but the actual levers of policy will be
firmly in the hands of the government
rather than one degree removed
this is not unique every government
wants tighter control over its economy
but for china the issue takes on a
particular urgency it cannot afford to
be late if doing so means seeding
control to a private company or worse a
foreign private company
for users though it will appear as
though china invented paypal or apple
pay
just one more app to use with no real
advantage
the problem won't be adoption if
necessary the government will simply
force it upon the public
the real challenge is international
adoption replacing the yuan with the
digital u.n is relatively easy but not
revolutionary
replacing the dollar with the un would
be revolutionary but is far from easy
the reason countries choose the dollar
is not because of its technical
superiority after all most financial
transactions are already digital just
ones and zeros moving from one account
to another
no the world chooses the dollar because
of its stability liquidity and
transparency three things which a
digital currency does absolutely nothing
to address
you'll know china is serious about
internationalizing the renminbi when it
makes the costly trade-off of removing
capital controls and letting its
exchange rate float freely
until then sources proclaiming the end
of the us dollar and threat of the
digital u.n are at best motivational
tools and at worst deceptive
fear-mongering
there is however another invention that
may help china evade sanctions if it
were to succeed it would mark the
beginning of a new era of u.s china
relations and separation it's called
cips and i explain what it is exactly
right now in the extended version of
this video on nebula
roughly every other polymatter video has
an extended or bonus version on nebula
plus there are no ads or sponsors and
even exclusive originals
just in the past week for example all
these channels have posted exclusive
bonus content on nebula including half
as interesting renee ritchie legal eagle
and thomas frank
my favorite recent original is kento
bento's beautifully animated story of
the most insane hijacking in japanese
history plus we've partnered with
curiositystream home to great
documentaries on technology history and
science like this one about the amazing
journey oil takes to get to our gas
stations so that you can get it and
nebula for less than 15 bucks a year
sign up with the link in the description
and watch the extended version of this
video over on nebula